ريال مدريد يدخل على خط قضيه اتهام
برشلونه بالفساد معارك بين زوجات النجوم
بسبب ممسحه الباب وكيف تعاقب الانديه
نجومها بعد الهزائم هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها عبر العربيه رياضه اسعدوا
بمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
باتت العلاقات الهادئه التي سيطرت على
المشهد بين قطبي الكره الاس
بانيه وبرشلونه مهدده بالانتهاء اداره
ريال مدريد الاسباني نشرت بيانا رسميا قبل
قليل اعربت فيه عن قلقها العميق اذا خطوره
الوقائع المقدمه ضد برشلونه والخاصه بتهاب
الفساد وتقديمه اموالا لنائب رئيس لجنه
الحكام في الدوري الاسباني بين عامي 2016
و2018 واشار النادي بحسب بيانه انه سيكون
طرفا في الاجراءات المتخذه بهدف دفاع عن
مصالحه المشروعه بمجرد فتح القاضي الباب
للاطراف المتضرره
تختلف عقوبات المدربين بحق لاعبيهم بعد
الهزائم الثقيله الهولنديه مدرب مانشستر
يونايتد الانجليزيه عاقبه لاعبهم مباشره
في غرفه الملابس بعد سباعيه ليفربول بفرض
الصمت ومشاهده احتفال منافسهم وفق ما
نقلته صحيفه
الى جانب التدريب الصباحي وما سبقه طبعا
من عبارات قاسيه تجاه اللاعبين الفرق
الايطاليه مثل ميلان ويوفنتوس فيعبد
المدربين على فرد اقامه اللاعبين في مراكز
التدريب وعدم العوده لمنازلهم لفتره طويله
اما عن الشافي مدرب برشلونه الاسباني
فيتبنى نظام الحرمان من العطل والاجازات
في وقت تفضل فيه اداره بعض الانديه فرضا
عقوبات ماليه
نتحول الان الى زوجات اللاعبين حيث ظهرت
انيكلنر زوجه كايل ووكر لاعب مانشستر سيتي
الانجليزي لاول مره في حاله محليه امس
الاحد اعاني ظهرت مرتديه لخاتم الزواج وسط
انباء عن غضبها من وصف صديقتها تبكى زوجه
جيمي باردي لاعب ليستر سيتي لها بانها
ممسحه الباب البائسه التي تريد لعب دور
الضحيه الامر لم يتوقف هنا في حرب النساء
حيث استغلت لورين كودمن والدته كايرو ابن
ووكر البكر الخلاف بين الصديقتين لمهاجمه
غريمتها وكتبت هي ايضا على الانستغرام
رساله موجهه لاني قائله توقفي عن اشعال
المشاكل وادعاء ان البعض يريد سرقه
الاضواء منك وتوقفي عن ادعاء محاوله
المحافظه على خصوصيه حياتك
[موسيقى]
الختام معروبين الذي هرب الى البرازيل
بهدف الافلات من العقاب الا ان لاعب ريال
مدريد وميلان ومانشستر سيتي السابق لا
يزال يواجه تداعيات حكم السجن تسع سنوات
اثر ثبوت اتهامه في قضيه اغتصاب بميلانو
عام 2013 وبحسب الصحف الارجنتينيه فان
الوزاره العامه الفيدراليه البرازيليه
والعداله الايطاليه عقدت اتفاقا جديدا
يقضي بقضاء اللاعب مده العقوبه في
البرازيل وعلى ذمه المنشور فقد تسربت
المعلومه للاعب البرازيلي
اللثه التي قدمها للسلطات ولم يتم العثور
عليه حط اللحظه